supongamos que tenemos una trayectoria
cerrada en el plano xy este de aquí es
el eje y el de acá es el eje x y la
trayectoria se ve más o menos así lo que
estoy intentando hacer es dibujar una
trayectoria más o menos arbitraria
ahora supongamos que vamos a empezar a
recorrerla en el sentido antihorario así
entonces caminamos sobre la trayectoria
en esta dirección vamos a ponerle un
nombre vamos a llamarle c supongamos que
también tenemos un campo vectorial y
nuestro campo vectorial le llamaremos p
de equis y lo único que va a tener este
campo vectorial son vectores múltiplos
de y el primer vector canónico es decir
va a ser del estilo p de xy multiplicada
por el vector unitario y no tiene nada
que ver con la componente j
entonces para visualizarlo voy a dibujar
unas flechas por acá y todos estos
vectores son horizontales son puros
múltiplos del vector y entonces pueden
ir hacia la izquierda o hacia la derecha
pero no van hacia arriba y hacia abajo
ni en diagonal voy a dibujar unos
cuantos más a ver le voy a poner como
'las entonces este campo vectorial se ve
más o menos así lo que quiero encontrar
es la integral de línea cerrada sobre la
trayectoria sobre la trayectoria c
qué cosas de dp punto de r
esta es la forma estándar de plantear
una integral de línea ya habíamos
hablado de que significa leer leer es
igual a de x por y más de y por j a lo
mejor aquí digas pero más bien era de x
/ de t por de t a ver déjame escribir
esto por aquí para para ver la forma
alternativa o sea de r es igual a b x /
de t por de t por i + d
/ de t por de t por jota ahora podría
ser así pero nos conviene más la primera
forma porque con un poco de suerte nos
evitaremos considerar el parámetro t que
es un tercer parámetro que parece estar
de más sale entonces lo vamos a ver con
dx y con de ella entonces vámonos
vámonos para acá otra vez y lo que
queremos hacer es reescribir esta
integral como la integral de línea sobre
c saber lo voy a hacer para acá para
tener un poco más de espacio la integral
de línea sobre la curva c o bien la
trayectoria c
punto de r es decir hay que multiplicar
los coeficientes de esta cosa de aquí
entonces lo único que vamos a obtener
son vectores con y por qué con j el
producto punto nos va a dar 0 luego a
poner aquí pd xy
v x
más y como te decía y punto j es igual a
0 entonces no va a aparecer la de ella
por ningún lado
entonces la integral queda simplificada
como esta expresión de acá entonces a
ver estas dos integrales de acá son las
integrales alrededor de esta trayectoria
ahora lo que les conté al principio es
que si tenemos suerte no vamos a tener
que lidiar con la tercera variable t tal
vez podamos resolver esta integral sólo
en términos de x vamos a ver si podemos
hacer esto comenzamos viendo los valores
mínimos que están por aquí vamos a
llamarle a y máximo que queda por acá de
x vamos a ponerle b entonces lo que
podemos hacer es quebrar esta curva en
dos funciones de x porque funciones de x
porque esta de aquí abajo vamos a
ponerle uno de equis estar acá es
simplemente una curva estándar así como
de las de cálculo de al principio y la
podemos pensar como una función de x
y luego de ahí tenemos la de acá arriba
vamos a ponerle 2 de x
sale entonces vamos a ponerlo así
podemos imaginarnos que hay un camino
una trayectoria aquí abajo definida por
uno de equis déjame ponerlo con color
rosa mexicano entonces lo voy a poner
aquí y uno de x que va desde x igualada
hasta x igual a b y luego hay un segundo
camino una segunda trayectoria que se
mueve conforme x se va bebé a ah
entonces recorre por aquí y esa es la
segunda curva entonces lo que podemos
hacer es reescribir esta integral que es
la misma que la original como a iba como
igual a la integral sobre este primer
camino es decir cuando aquí se mueve de
ave de p de x
y pues podría poner px pero ahora ya
sabemos que sobre esta trayectoria y es
una función de x entonces vamos a
ponerle ya 1 b x
siempre que veamos una llevamos a
cambiarla por uno de ellos y aquí hay
que integrar de equis ahora eso de ahí
cubre la primera parte de la curva
entonces esto que estoy marcando con los
a mexicanos vamos a llamarle c1 que es
la primer mitad de nuestra curva pero
aún nos falta la segunda mitad verdad
entonces vamos a reescribir lo de la
segunda mitad al lado derecho es decir
ahora que nos toca hacer nos toca hacer
la curva en amarillo entonces vamos a
sumar vamos a sumar la integral pero
ahora la equis se mueve debe hasta a y
entonces ahora que hay que ponerle b y
aquí
y lo que hay que poner ahora es a ver
voy a ponerle así pe de equis y ahora
que se mueve con respecto a 72 de x
entonces tenemos que sustituir por de 2
de x entonces 2 de x
e integramos con respecto a x sale
entonces esto de aquí ya se está
poniendo un poco interesante vamos a
llamarle c2 a lo mejor de aquí ya ves
más o menos que queremos hacer y bueno
vamos a trabajar un poquito más vale
ahora que este que dijimos hasta ahorita
simplemente dividimos nuestra curva en
dos en dos partes ahora lo que queremos
hacer es pues juntarlas entonces vamos a
intercambiar ahí ve aquí para cambiar el
signo vamos a ponerle aquí ve aquí vamos
a ponerle a y aquí hay que ponerle un
menos hasta ahorita no hemos cambiado
nada del valor de la integral vamos a
ponerle igual a la integral de ave de
qué cosa de esta expresión de fe de x
coma de 19 x
y luego tenemos que restar esta
expresión
- p de x2 de x
sale y todo esto hay que integrarlo con
respecto a x voy a poner un paréntesis y
ponerle b x
baja ahora voy a hacer algo que parece
un poco arbitrario pero al final vas a
apreciar por qué hice esto que voy a
hacer lo que voy a hacer es intercambiar
estos dos multiplicando por un menos es
decir voy a cambiar el signo a los dos
suman 2 y hasta fuera para compensar voy
a poner un menos y entonces la expresión
no habrá cambiado en nada entonces eso
es lo que vamos a hacer hay tema vamos a
intercambiarlas entonces voy a ponerle
igual a la integral de ave y voy a
conservar los colores para que no nos
para que no nos confundamos aquí dejo de
x entonces lo de aquí adentro lo
multiplicó por menos entonces voy a
poner primero el término en amarillo pd
x2 de x y luego voy a restar y pongo en
color rosa
dx coma y uno de x
ahora lo que me falta hacer todavía es
multiplicar por un menos para que no
haber afectado en nada la integral
entonces voy a multiplicar afuera de la
integral por un signo menos y entonces
estas dos expresiones son iguales esto
de aquí es lo mismo que acá son
simplemente los negativos negativos el
uno del otro entonces son exactamente la
misma expresión vamos a movernos abajo
para tener un poco más de espacio y en
el siguiente paso vamos a hacer otra
cosa que se ve todavía más arbitraria de
lo que acabamos de hacer pero al final
vamos a llegar a un resultado que es muy
muy bonito
entonces fíjate vamos a trabajar al
revés vamos a escribir menos la integral
de aa b
de lo siguiente a ver lo voy a poner con
un nuevo color de la función p de x
evaluada en c2 de x
- la función evaluada a ver déjame
déjame borrarlo voy a ponerle de igual a
2 de x para que sea todavía más claro y
hay que restar la función en que iguala
y 1 de x
afuera voy a dejar el de x sale entonces
esta expresión y esta de acá las dos son
iguales déjame marcar aquí arriba con
rosa mexicano entonces esta expresión y
la expresión de abajo son idénticas
ahora qué vamos a hacer para el
siguiente paso para el siguiente paso
vamos a hacer la cosa más arbitraria de
todo el vídeo ahora si lo que vamos a
hacer es suponer que mete una derivada
parcial con respecto a y entonces déjame
ponerle una igualdad por acá lo que voy
a hacer es copiar la integral de afuera
así como menos la integral aquí van los
límites va de a a b
y luego aquí tenemos que poner un de
equis sale entonces esta expresión de
aquí vamos a suponer que tiene una
derivada parcial con respecto a y
entonces vamos a reescribir esto pero en
una forma integral a qué me refiero con
eso aquí aquí voy a poner la derivada
parcial con respecto a y aquí afuera voy
a poner un deje y voy a integrar con
límite inferior a 1 de x el límite
superior 2 de x sale entonces quiero que
te sientas muy cómodo con que estas dos
cosas son iguales entonces déjame
explicar un poco más porque para ver
esto lo mejor es empezar del lado
derecho e ir hacia el lado izquierdo
porque porque en el lado derecho tenemos
una integral doble y entonces lo primero
que hacemos en una integral doble cuando
la intentamos resolver es tomar la parte
de adentro esta de aquí y lo que tenemos
que hacer es tomar la anti derivada de
lo que esté aquí adentro con respecto a
ella pero la anti derivada de la parcial
de p con respecto a y con respecto a y
simplemente es p entonces regresamos
aquí
estas de aquí los límites de integración
caen acá para evaluar en
dos de equis y luego restarle x entonces
usualmente comenzaríamos con la derecha
y acabaríamos con algo como lo de la
izquierda aquí estamos haciendo algo un
poco inusual porque estamos empezando al
revés
lo que hacemos es empezar a la izquierda
y trabajar hacia la derecha y entonces
estamos como que creando integrales
entonces bueno con un poco de suerte me
vas a creer que estoy aquí es cierto
pero ya con eso vamos a establecer un
resultado muy bonito porque ahora vamos
a reescribir esto en términos de una
integral doble con todo y su región de
integración vamos a ver esto que es en
el dibujo fíjate tenemos la derivada de
p con respecto al yen entonces eso de
ahí es una función es una función que
está definida en el plano xy entonces
voy a dibujar acá dejamos borrar voy a
dibujar por acá el eje y el eje x y por
acá el eje z y lo que estamos haciendo
aquí y aquí xy lo que estamos haciendo
es que esta función nos determina una
superficie acá
entonces ponemos una superficie
y en donde estamos evaluando esta doble
integral pues estamos tomando la doble
integral debajo de esta superficie
en la región que está dada por estos
límites de integración entonces vámonos
al dibujo para ver qué quiere decir esto
tenemos un 2 de x por acá esa es la
curva 2 y por aquí abajo vamos a poner
el 1 que nos determina la curva 1
entonces esencialmente estamos tomando
el volumen sobre esta región de aquí que
es la región que queda encerrada por la
curva sé nada más y nada menos que acá
entonces fíjate esto está muy padre la
altura cuál es la altura es la parcial
de p con respecto a y entonces la altura
que voy a dibujarlo a ver voy a ponerlo
por aquí de noche y creo que no cabe
pero esencialmente lo que estamos
haciendo es encontrar el volumen de un
sólido como ya lo habíamos hecho en
vídeos pasados entonces lo que está
padre es que si a esta región de aquí le
ponemos r lo que logramos hacer es
cambiar esta integral de línea que sólo
tenía un componente en x en su campo
vectorial la logramos simplificar o
bueno la logramos hacer igual
lo siguiente lo que vamos a hacer igual
a verbal nos vamos a escribir lo mejor
aquí abajo entonces vamos a poner esto
que la integral de c
la integral de línea de p de xy de x es
igual a qué cosa pues a la integral
doble a la integral doble sobre la
región r
la región r que está encerrada por la
curva entonces vamos a ponerle aquí
abajo la región r de qué cosa pues de la
parcial de p con respecto a y la parcial
la parcial de p
con respecto a y vamos a ponerle de de
equis o puedes ponerle de equis de g
o lo que quieras pero esto de aquí es
una integral doble sobre esa región lo
que está bonito es que usando un campo
vectorial que sólo tiene una entrada en
x pudimos pasar la integral de línea a
una integral doble creo que me falta
algo por aquí verdad un signo menos que
va aquí abajo también entonces aquí
también hay que poner el menos que
bonito va en el próximo vídeo vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo pero con un
campo vectorial con vectores sólo en
dirección y conectando ambos resultados
vamos a llegar a un resultado bien bien
padre